- Hey, everybody.
(audience chattering)
Thanks for joining in.
What we're gonna talk about
today is probably something
that is on the minds of
many people around here.
We're gonna talk about LLMs
and observability together,
which is probably a very interesting topic
for a lot of you guys moving into Bedrock,
using OpenAI, using
Anthropic, using whatever,
and we're gonna focus
on how we do it right.
So let's start with why LLM
observability even matters.
I think that probably 99% of
you guys use LLM to some form,
but why does observability
and kind of monitoring
them, why does it matter?
We started, you know, just
maybe a couple years ago,
we like simple flows of an agent
or a model that I query, get a response,
everything was simple,
and now we have a ton
of complication, right?
Multi-turn agents, multiple
steps with, you know,
different functionalities,
kind of using different agent,
different models to get
into a final outcome.
We have retrieval pipelines, right?
Like Rug that enrich that embed,
that create a data pipeline
up to the actual model at the end.
Any silent failure on any of these
will screw up the entire process, right?
We have tool augmentation.
Our workflows now use scripts and APIs
and different stuff that
basically kind of comprehends
the entire workflow,
what we're trying to do.
Something goes wrong,
something is high latency,
and the entire workflow
study doesn't work, right?
Now, you wanna observe a
lot of different things
that you're already thinking about
if you're using LLMs today, right?
The most common things we hear
about is token usage, right?
All of these pricing models
are connected somehow
to token usage, to kind
of on demand capacity
that you're querying, one
million tokens of contacts,
it just keeps growing, right?
You wanna monitor that.
You wanna know how much
your users are using
and you have no control of that
because eventually your
developers are the ones
that making a choice of how many tokens
is being inputted and outputted, right?
Response latency.
AI has gotten into production
quicker than we would imagine, right?
The value was so high that we
just rushed into production.
It eventually, your APIs
depends on it today, right?
If you're serving a customer-facing API
and using AI in the middle,
any latency there can impact
hundreds of percent of
your latency suddenly
just because you wanted that value.
Same for error rates, right?
If a model suddenly replies with an error,
which happens due to structure issues
or to anything that can happen,
and you don't know about it,
your API can suddenly go wrong.
Before it was all a
box you can control on,
now it's getting more complex.
And the fourth thing, and
maybe the most sensitive one
is LLM responses, right?
How do I detect hallucinations?
How do I know that the
response is even correct?
Any of you that tried
to query an LLM 50 times
for the same thing got 50
different results, right?
And eventually we want to figure out
how to kind of monitor and
figure out what's going on.
Now, the challenges are that the speed
in which your stack is changing
has never been as fast as now, right?
We've implemented AI into
production, skipping security,
skipping privacy, skipping
anything in your companies
to get value into production
and into your customers, right?
And anything that kind of prohibited
that value was put aside,
but right now you're
introducing a new tool
every month, right, from Cloud Code
to anything that is creating
even code into your production
to actual AI used in your
workflows to get value
to your customers, right?
The rating with this is
changing is higher than the rate
that you can observe,
instrument your code,
instrument your application to even track
and monitor what you're doing.
I'm sure that 50% of the
companies here are not even sure
what models you're using
right now in production
just because of the
pace things are changing
and things are examined.
The second thing is the
sensitivity of data.
AI eventually creates a
very interesting situation
where user input can be
incredibly sensitive, right?
It can be not even something
that depends on you.
What happens if your
application exposes a chatbot
to your end user?
They can input a very
sensitive information
about their customers, about themselves,
that you might never
wanted in your application,
but now you can control and
now you're responsible for.
So who gets to upload what?
Where the data goes?
Who stores it?
Which third party am I relying on?
That's a big part of the challenges
around LLM observability.
Groundcover does things very different
around observability in general,
but it has a lot to do with how
people should think about LLM.
Most of the people, most of you all
is currently using Bedrock, for example,
with AWS, has similar concerns.
The first thing that
groundcover does differently
is that we use a
bring-your-own-cloud architecture.
Basically, instead of
being a simple SaaS model
where we store the data of
all the monitoring telemetry
that you send out and present it to you,
we deploy and manage an
observability backend
on your cloud premises
in your AWS account.
It's fully managed, it's fully hands-off
like a SUS experience,
but you get the value of
data privacy, data residency,
and full control of what's being stored
without us processing it, storing it,
or removing it from your environment.
We also use eBPF, which we're
gonna talk about in a second,
which is a kernel-level visibility
to instrument your application
at the speed you write them in, right?
If you introduce a Bedrock
application tomorrow,
it's instantly instrumented
with eBPF without you doing anything.
And again, the pace in
which things are moving
is higher than what you can predict.
Those two combined, the
data collection with eBPF
and bring your own cloud to
store it cost effectively
and private is what allows us
also to build on experiences
which are high granularity,
which we'll show in a second,
of how LLMS observability
can actually look like.
So what is eBPF?
eBPF is basically a
kernel-level capability,
kind of a superpower that
allows us to look into what APIs
and microservices are doing
without you instrumenting code.
With LLMs and AI, it gets
even more important, right?
You can literally cover
your production now,
any AI involved without
modifying your applications,
without even redeploying production,
without adding an SDK into
your code, which again,
you wanna get to value of very quickly,
you don't wanna do it, right?
Second, we get kernel-level visibility.
We can actually capture
the full API requests
and responses, the actual payload,
so we can see the prompts,
we can see the responses,
we can see what's actually
being transmitted,
so you get the visibility
to figure out what's happening,
and we can translate
that to realtime insights
because suddenly you have
access to token usage,
to reasoning path, to
LLM calls and error rates
to actually correlate
them to logs, metrics,
traces collected outside
of your environment,
outside of that LLM application.
And the bring-your-own-cloud piece
is basically what allows us to do it
so securely and privately.
Basically what it means is
that we've found the balance
between a managed service
and an on-prem deployment.
We separate the control
plane and the data plane.
So the data plane that
you can see on the left
is basically being hosted in a sub account
in your AWS environment,
but the control plane that
manages the infrastructure
scales it, updates it, provides the SLA
that you deserve from
an observability company
is being run by groundcover on our side.
We have no access to your data.
We don't store it, we don't process it.
You don't have to rely on us for security
and privacy of your GDPR sensitive
and very kind of business critical data.
That allows us to do a
few interesting things.
First is protect LLM pipelines
from data exposure, right?
You can now capture very sensitive data
on what your users are doing with your AI
without worrying that this data
will be tracked or shipped anywhere.
All this data has been
stored in your premises
with groundcover, and there's
no third party storage,
no outbound communication,
no egress of this data
to anywhere that you need
to be concerned about.
The second is that you
can actually use this
to improve performance and manage spend,
which is, again, with all the value of AI,
this is becoming a critical issue
that everybody wants to
take a look at, right?
You can look at token
usage, latency, throughputs,
we're gonna see example of error rates
and things that we're gonna dive deep
into the demo in a second.
And the third and most important thing,
you can actually monitor LLM
responses with the context
that allows you to do
something with it, right?
Maybe I wanna look at response payload.
I wanna see which tools the LLM used
or chose to use in the actual application.
I wanna see a history of
path that the LLM chose
to eventually do stuff,
and I wanna figure out
what variance is my user's
getting from my deployed AI,
what's actually working and what's not.
All of this can be deployed in minutes.
Install the sensor.
It has an auto discovery.
You don't have to tell it
that you're just instrumented
Bedrock into your application.
It will auto detect it and
suddenly we'll see Bedrock APIs
going out of your microservices
and they will be monitored
and correlated to all the other
insights that you collect,
like log management,
infrastructure monitoring,
and all the things you're used to seeing.
Jumping into a quick demo,
just to kinda show you
how that might look like.
Sorry about that.
So with groundcover,
basically the first thing
that you're gonna see is
all of your deployments
and what's running inside the cluster.
You can also see a dependency map
of who's communicating to who.
In this case specifically,
I can say filter Bedrock
and see shop-service, which
is a regular microservice
running on my Kubernetes cluster,
communicating with the Bedrock service
through Bedrock traces that
I could actually observe.
The second thing that we
can look at is actually see
our API calls, in this
case, focus on Bedrock,
I can see which models
I'm using in general,
what's the latency, what's the throughput,
how many of these being used.
Just to emphasize, anything
that you're seeing here,
you didn't do anything to get.
The eBPF sensor, just collects it
once you deploy a demon
set on your EKS cluster
and you're good to go.
AI information and context is
being collected immediately.
Let's look at a cool example.
This is the tracer screen groundcover.
Basically the eBPF sensor
will collect any trace
that flows through the system.
We can focus, for example,
on anything that is Bedrock-related.
I wanna see, you know, what's
flowing through the cluster
and I can immediately see flows
that are even wider than Bedrock.
In this specific example,
I can see a service map
of a client communicating
to another a service,
and then I can see Bedrock being executed
in the middle at some point, right,
where AI needs to be involved.
The cool thing about it is like,
I can actually see the full eBPF context
of what's happening.
I can see the request model that you use,
the response model, the
tokens that are being used.
I can see the chat, right?
I can see the prompt and the
response from the server.
I can see the raw request
in case I wanna figure out
exactly what was transmitted,
and I can even see correlation to things
that you care about, like clogs, right?
In this case, shop-service was telling me
that it's about to create an AI greeting.
In this case, it created
some kind of greeting
with the AI service and I can
correlate it with the logs
and even with the
infrastructure monitoring tool,
so how much is that AI being called from
in front of Bedrock?
What is the actual latency?
What is the CPO of the container?
Anything that I wanna take a look at,
and all of this was correlated at the edge
by the eBPF sensor without
you thinking about it,
instrumenting, notifying the sensor
what to take a look at, right,
'cause eventually you're
removing really quick.
The other thing we can
look at is errors, right?
In this case, this is an example
of a Bedrock Anthropic model that failed
and I can see the actual prompt
and the response so that in this case,
in case of kind of IAM problem
that I couldn't eventually
use the relevant model
or kind of approach the
relevant Bedrock service,
troubleshooting that without
observability would require
someone from the DevOps to
figure out what's going on.
In this case, a developer
that is experimenting
and trying to deploy this to production
can now see what's going on.
Another interesting example
that we can take a look at
is basically trying to explore this data
in ways that can help you
build business context on top of that.
We can take a look at our traces.
In this case, for example,
take a look at P90 latency
of any model that we use.
So in this case, I can
actually take a look
over a specific period of time.
I can look at which models
are the high-latency models
that I wanna take take a look at, right?
In this case, Anthropic is
one of the high-latency ones.
There's a few faster ones that
are maybe operating better.
Now I can correlate that with token usage.
I can correlate that with value,
with specific APIs that
trigger these models
and I can make decisions, right?
I can also do the same for token usage.
I can suddenly take a
look at any token usage
that I have inside the platform and say,
"You know what, I wanna figure out
what is the actual usage of tokens
across by different models."
And I'll make a decision
about should I really use this model?
Is this equivalent to the
quota I was expecting?
What is my team doing?
What are they building?
So I can figure out what's going on.
We can also do more sophisticated stuff
that will eventually allow
us to dive into areas
where we care about for actual SLA
in front of our customers.
Say that, you know, I'm using Bedrock,
but I also wanna figure out anything
that is of duration
above one second, right,
because that's the SLA that
I promise my customers.
Anything that, any API
that crosses one second
kind of affects my SLA that
I guarantee to my customers.
First of all, I can see the
actual traces that causes this.
I can actually take a
look at that example,
in this case, a 1.4 second
response from Bedrock,
and I can see, okay, what's going on?
What's the actual flow?
But also what's the prompt
that triggered that?
What's the context?
Why is it taking so long?
The second thing that
I can do is drill down
on this specific filter and figure out
if there's anything I should care about.
Is there any model that
is taking care of that?
Is there any specific token
usage that might be triggering
that specific latency?
Am I seeing that high latency only on like
very big prompts, very big context,
or very specific workflows?
That is very valuable.
Just getting into this
data and correlating
and figuring out what's
going on, that's really hard.
I can also take a look at the
relevant workloads, right?
Who eventually is the service
that is responsible for any of these?
What's creating these queries
inside my specific environment?
The second thing I could
do is set alerts, right?
Now that you have all this
data and you care about SLA
and you know that if this
specific SLA is breached,
you wanna know why not just
create a monitor of that,
that you can now use to alert your teams
and alert yourself that
something is going on,
so in this specific case,
if there's an LLM SLA
breach, I might wanna know.
Every time that it crosses one second,
I wanna get notified and look how easy
that was without you doing anything
because the traces were
there, the context were there,
and now you could just need
to define the business value
of what you care about.
Anything that revolves around
that can now be created
into dashboards, right?
The things that are repetitive
that you should care about
for a longer period of time,
that you want to even
share with your customers,
that you want people to be
aware of when you're using AI,
which models and vendors am I using?
What's the latency?
How is token usage behaving over time?
Am I crossing my quota?
Am I in a good state?
How is latency behaving
over time and who to blame?
Which models am I using?
Have I introduced a new model?
Is something kind of moving around?
Is it related to a version
that I wanna focus on?
Anything that we've seen so far
can basically be baked into monitors,
dashboards, and things that
can be repetitively used
to dive into what you're looking at.
Baking that into the
context of your production,
your dependency map,
who's communicating with who
is what eventually can drive
the information, the value
that you need to your business.
Going back a bit to kind
of the start where we were,
all of this is basically achieved
with a very innovative
approach to how we monitor AI.
If up until now, you
had to instrument an SDK
into your code, pick and
choose what you wanna monitor.
I've instrumented the new AI
applications into my code.
I now need to instrument
the functions using it
and notify my SDK, my open telemetry SDK,
or whatever I'm using,
I need to notify that,
that this is important for me
while my developers are running forward,
now I can deploy an eBPF sensor
and get the value immediately.
If before I had to redeploy production
or test things that staging and dev,
now production is running
and it's covered in 30
seconds from deployment,
and also I can store logs, metrics,
and traces in the same environment
under my bring your own cloud,
not worry about data residency,
not worry about privacy, not
worry about data security,
and not worry about
creating a new sub processor
that might concern my customers
and get all this value.
Thank you for listening.
If there's any follow-up questions,
first of all, you can find us
in the yellow shirt
booth right over there.
Can't miss us.
I'll be right over here for any questions
or follow-ups that come up.
We have a playground
that you can check out
at play.groundcover.com where
you can see all this demo
and play with it yourselves.
I'm sure that it will kind
of give way to new questions,
so feel free to try it out.
We have a free tier and we're over there
and just happy to answer any questions.
Thank you for the time.
(audience applauding)